i mean barry i love this album i love
this song
and dolly i understand barry called you
and asked you to do this how quickly did
you say
yes as quick as i got the word that he
wanted me to sing it
i said yes i mean i love the song and i
love barry so
i mean what what else did i need
that's very true and barry what was it
like being in the same recording studio
with the iconic dolly
iconic i mean absolutely um incredible
and uh when when dolly walks in
the room lights up and everything's
great you know
every other artist i know says the same
thing nobody can actually
it's very difficult it glows in the dark
so that was a pure pleasure oh i bet it
was we were in the we were in the
we were in the studio where the evil
brothers made their records with roy
orbison and elvis and
you know the environment the atmosphere
and the environment
and the ambience of that room and the
amount of
legendary artists that have been in
there it's a bit like doing the aubry
you know you're standing on that stage
yeah it was like for me i recorded some
of my early records there and just
being back in that studio with barry
really just
had a magical feeling to think yes you
yeah you belong in the studio with all
those greats you belong in here and i'm
i was just happy to be here well you're
very kind you're very kind dolly
you know i've i've just always looked
for a place to belong
and and i think we do that through our
lives we never really feel that we
belong anywhere
if you're anything like me you you feel
like you're an outsider no matter what
and you look for a place to belong or a
purpose
and and for me that's
uh nashville is where i belong musically
i can't make my whole family move there
because they all grew up here
but but uh but the music of nashville
the soul of nashville the spirituality
and the great songs
there's somewhere in this country where
great songs are being written and
i love being a part of that in any
measure
oh i love that and dolly i feel like
you're both perfectionist
but who do you trust like who's your
litmus
test on all of it and who do you trust
to go to
when you're recording something well i
truly am not a perfectionist
i think barry probably is i just love to
sing a lot of times i'll let loose
things go you know it's like
if i got the right feel and the right
attitude i'll even let a wrong cord on a
guitar go by
if the whole thing fits good but to me i
i'm just all about
getting the right you know the right
feel and the right
emotion but i work with all these great
musicians and producers
that know how to get all that and to get
it
good and hopefully to capture you know
all that but it doesn't have to be
perfect to be great to be perfectly
wonderful
right nothing will ever be perfect so
you you try as hard as you can to get as
close as you can but there is no such
thing
you know right and that's the beauty
about music i think that's what makes
music so
individual and so wonderful yeah well i
do too
and yeah and it's not about categories
really is it it's about
any kind of music i love opera as much
as i love country music
i love pavarotti as much as as much as i
like um
george strait well you love the grand
old opera
right i surely even love the grand old
opera
my life story i'm doing dolly a grand
old opry
that's great i love it that's great but
you're right
i think every there's something great in
every in all music and
and i think music truly is i have a line
in in a song
that i wrote it's called music is the
voice of the soul there'll always be
music because that just is how we that's
the one thing that can bring us together
i think more than almost any other thing
yeah and it also brings you back to a
place i feel like music has such a
beautiful ability to transform you
you know barry and the bee gees were
responsible some of the greatest songs
of all time including
yes a song that means so much to me and
my dad my dad used to sing this which
was islands in the stream
um it's just it it like it makes me well
up it just means so much to me and to
our family
what does that song mean to you now
for me either one let's go with barry
then we'll go to dolly
well it changed my life i mean islands
in the stream
changed our lives because we couldn't
get on the radio as an artist as the
artist itself
because we'd reached a stage in our life
where things were changing and people
didn't want to play bg's records
so we had to get out but that's before
fever you know oh no that's not true
it's after fever
and but we also suffered from that
before fever so it was it was a
a regular sort of here's your downer
you're up on here's your downer that was
our lives
so i was in the stream we were in the
middle of writing
when kenny called up and asked if i had
a song
or a couple of songs and i said well
kenny i'd rather do an album than a
couple of songs and that was
that was not something i should have
said because he said okay
oh no now i've got to do a whole help so
so i did it you know and
and uh anderson the stream was a part of
that and he said well i'd like it to be
a duet
they said and i you know i love this
lady dolly pardon and i said of course
and he said i'm gonna call her so and
that's my
feeling about what happened but um but
then
it all came down to as far as kenny is
concerned that it all happened in one
day when we
we in fact had to find all these keys so
i knew i knew it wasn't one day
you know yeah and for you
what is that memory of that song mean to
you
well first of all that song in a lot of
ways changed my
my life because i was working with two
men that i loved dearly i'd always
i always thought the world of kenny i
always loved his voice i never thought
all the years that we worked together i
never got tired of it
and then i'd always loved barry and the
bee gees
everything they ever did i loved and so
getting to
actually be on something that big and
kenny was very big at the time you know
as an artist and for me to even be asked
to sing on that record but then
when it became such a huge hit it opened
up a lot of things for kenny and i to do
together
we we did concerts and so it really
added many elements to
my life and to be part of a song that's
considered one of the
greatest records of all time and
everywhere i go
people say islands in the stream they
don't even say hello
they just
everyone knows it became a karaoke thing
for some reason
but obvious reasons you know
but um don't know how old that works but
you're right
it changes everything around you it
leads to other things you might not have
and it done great for us great for us
for all the fans be part of it yeah yeah
and for all the fans it really does
transport you back to a
a special time so thank you for that
gift it's it's really something special
um do you remember barry the first time
you heard dolly sing that song and what
was going through your mind
yeah i do it was like an explosion it
was like um
was it yeah dolly didn't come in until
that second verse so it was all kenny
the first person the first chorus and i
was in the stream so forth
but when it came to dolly's turn to sing
um
everything just caught fire it just lit
up and
and we knew then we knew right there and
then that this was a number one record
and kenny was fine but dolly was on fire
and within two or three takes oh yeah
uh within two or three times it's so
good yeah we
we we've got it in about two takes three
takes maybe
oh wow that's so stunning you know this
album is full of people that you respect
me when you wanted to work with people
like dolly little big town
keith urban miranda lambert talk about
the importance of having the textures of
all those different voices
well it's impossible because um because
the stars just aligned it wasn't like
it wasn't like i knew who was going to
sing each song
i would only have i would only have um
said if i did we didn't even discuss
what songs dolly you could have sung any
song you wanted but um i didn't i didn't
know that you were being given a list
that was
nothing i had anything to do with that
and
i think between jay landers and dave
cobb and people like that dave kopp
visited me here
words of a fool he said he never even
listened to it he said that's fine we'll
do that one
and and butterfly julian welsh and dave
rawlings
and that was written in 1966 and
there's a couple of songs words of a
fool was written about 1984
so i wanted to have a couple of songs at
least on that album that people were not
necessarily aware of
so but as i've said before
without dolly i don't think these people
would have jumped in as quickly as they
did
oh i love that and dolly you've been
collaborating with lots of people this
year
including our michael buble um to your
goddaughter miley and
barry is there someone who's still on
your list to collaborate with
well i don't really have anyone in mind
they just seem to fall when they're
supposed to
you know just i didn't plan to sing with
any of these people things just kind of
seemed to happen
and when barry had asked me to sing on
words it's one of my favorite songs
ever and i've i've been singing that
song ever since it was a hit for them
years ago and when i saw that list maybe
they just sent me
a list of all bg songs yeah you would
have had a choice no matter what god
and i would and i picked that one and so
but i really uh i just love the song i'm
glad you're dead
i'm glad and i thought that one fit our
voice i just always believed
uh that our i thought back when you and
and your brothers were singing
i used to sing along all the time and i
thought our voices were similar
that he might actually yeah
all three of us didn't sing on that song
no i know but i'm saying all of the
songs
when y'all would sing i would relate so
to those
the tones and the voices but yeah i know
you and i know your stuff
and i knew that i could sing that one
great with you
and you did and you did and i thought
our voices were just exactly what i
thought they'd be
and i'm very proud of that thank you you
know what i could just sit here
all day and watch you too and listen and
hear the stories but i know i'm gonna
get in trouble and i have to share you
with the rest of the world
so i'm gonna say goodbye and just say
thank you so much what a beautiful song
beautiful album congratulations to both
of you and stay safe
we'll see you soon you too thank you
bye-bye
you